[Music]
what an evil person that you cannot
as a man take care of the woman that you
married let alone give a diary you
asking for dowry
yeah you bully her you bully her so much
to the uh
to push her to that word and then on top
of that you tell her to
send you a video
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products salaam
alaikum
today better care to your brothers and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
are going shallow welcome to this video
in this video brought my sister's a
sister called sister aisha um i'm gonna
find out why
this tragedy happened what caused it so
here's the video
uh let's get straight into inshallah
[Music]
[Music]
foreign you can see from the video the
sorrow in her eyes
this last bit specifically here you can
see the sorrow in her eyes even though
she's trying to hide it
let's carry on
father said that she was harassed by her
in-laws for diary and was eventually
sent to her parents house by her husband
as per reports police obtained i should
cause records with shaw she had a 17
minute long conversation with iris
before taking the extreme step
alif had reportedly told his wife if you
want to die then die
but send me a video first
aisha's father said that he had
initially paid 1.5
luck in dowry but her lords in those
demanded more
brothers and sisters i'm going to go to
a verse in the quran
yeah and subhanallah any time whenever
we do not obey by the commands of allah
these tragedies happen
all the time we do not learn lessons
well allah prescribed
we don't take it and when we don't take
it subhanallah we suffer it's like a
medication that you
have to take it's bitter it's disgusting
but it's good for you
and the more we turn a blind eye to this
reality
what happens is we all end up suffering
brothers and sisters subhanallah yeah
in this verse allah subhanahu wa says
men are caretakers of women
since allah has made some of them excel
the others and because of the wealth
they have spent
so the righteous women are obedient and
god the property and the honor of their
husbands in their absence with the
protection given by allah
and allah talks about us for the
rebellious women and the precautions to
be taken
step by step okay now here unless one
tells very clear saying that men
are the providers the maintainers the
caretakers of women yeah
now i know sadly uh the whole feminist
movement has
made this out to be as if it's some kind
of you know
uh women are just you know they can't
work et cetera no
allah saying that men have to take care
of their wives okay
even so much so when it comes to the
dowry it's the men that give the diary
not the woman in this very instant to
say traditions from the hindu indians
uh subhanallah that the woman has to
give the diary i've never heard
something like this in my life it's such
a
bizarre thing so finance ajib yeah allah
stated clearly that the men are the ones
that give them not
vice versa because of the status of a
woman subhanallah
and not only that when it comes to
caretaking and maintaining this is the
same
principle that applies me personally
when it comes to for example for my wife
etc
there might be times where i might have
a difficulty with payments
uh for a com for example say when it
comes to rent yeah and my wife may allah
bless her has said you know what i can
contribute
and i said look thank you may allah
bless you but no that's my duty but this
doesn't mean
that in a very lucky i was really really
struggling and there's not a problem yet
she doesn't have to the question here is
this the point is she does not
have to when it comes to shopping the
rent and things that she needs
to a certain extent there's a limit okay
this is what i can give a week etc here
okay and the thing is if that's what i
can provide i can say okay this one i
can provide anything that
extra she wants that i cannot she has a
right to go on work but the point is is
even the mind that's given to her that's
her you cannot touch it
this is the status that islam has given
to women if you read this book
yeah it's by james thule the the miss
education of woman i want to read the
one specific bit brothers and sisters
yeah
it says women magazines are full of
stories about women's current
unhappiness and service
explore why top sunday the uk's
best-selling health and beauty magazine
for instance revealed it in a summer
2001 survey that
only nine percent of working women and
four percent of women with their
preschool children say they choose to
work full-time
in fact if given the chance 78 of all
working women would quit their jobs
tomorrow if they could and a similar
percentage think that their work is
damaging their health
causing ailments such as headaches
constant exhaustion backache anxiety
forgetfulness insomnia
irritable bowel syndrome and migraine
family life says the
report is being driven to the breaking
point by a woman's current lifestyles
so this man this evil man you
have killed her you have killed her you
have
caused her death why
look look if somebody's coming and
seeing their suicidal or for example
they're going to kill themselves
what kind of a vile person do you have
to be to say to that person you know
what
um if you're going to do it record
yourself you're an evil person
and knowing that you're a coward let me
tell you why you're a coward because
allah said you are the protector and the
maintainer
you did not protect her you pushed her
to the point
yeah you pushed it you played a part i'm
not going to say it's totally your fault
you played a massive part okay this
sister
may allah forgive her yes some scholars
say that people commit suicide you know
you're not
supposed to forgive this difference
depending on the matter but may allah
have mercy and i forgive her okay
we know the answer that hadith the
process said the one who kills the self
commits suicide will kill themselves
that way till the day of judgment yeah
and the point is this but allah says he
will forgive any sin except
so it's highest discretion with us allah
subhanallah have mercy on him
mercy on her but you are supposed to be
the protector how did your protector
you greedy person you greedy violent
animal what you're asking for
who the hell are you who the hell are
you why should diary be given to you
i was telling you you have to give diary
to her number one
protector you didn't protect you failed
you failed just as this verse talks
about the extreme
uh uh rebellious woman and how to uh the
precautions are in place to de-escalate
the situation it's about a rebellious
woman
when allah tells you that you should
take a main uh protector and
maintain a caretaker of a woman you are
the other evil
you are the other evil yeah you didn't
protect her
and you can't even maintain her what
kind of a man are you
what kind of man are you i don't give a
damn this whole uh feministic
um perception of you know we go on days
everyone pays 50 50. remember
everything is equal you know everything
we got this is nonsense
yes men are there to protect and
maintain
the the the woman yeah look after them
inshallah yeah this doesn't make them
unable to look after themselves but that
is right allah has given it so much so
that today feminism the feminist
movement has made it seem as if that's a
bad thing you know
it's no no no it's a bad thing you know
well i'm a misindependent yeah okay
until you reach
ages of 30 a career woman 40 can't have
kids you're left alone and this was
having a pandemic
of korea woman uh realizing that they
are lonely you know
so panel so probably this is in a
nutshell i asked allah how to deal with
this person
um what an evil person that you cannot
as a man
take care of the woman that you married
let alone give a diary you asking for
diary
yeah you bully her you bully her so much
to the uh
to push onto that verd and then on top
of that you tell her to
send you a video before killing yourself
subhanallah are you going to answer
allah under their judgment
brothers and sisters well this is what
we're saying if you abandon the quran
and the sunnah you are bound to suffer
and just as we tell the brothers to fix
up
and act like men if we was to do the
same about our sisters when it comes to
in the very verse he says and women
those
righteous women who are obedient to
their husband obedient oh my gosh
oh how dare you say that well your
brothers and sisters my dear sister
specifically yeah we're calling out a
brother
for his wrongdoings what he's not
following what allah has ordered
yeah okay and we are asking the woman
obedient to whom
a good man nobody's asking you to be
obedient to a man who is violating your
eyes like this person do you think i was
talking about obedience to this kind of
men
huh let's be rohingya we ask allah
to forgive her and we ask this guy to
repent and wallahi that's the hakka
that of this person under their judgment
it's going to be peak it's going to be
people and sisters inshallah
share this with your friends and family
well it's very disturbing and so sad
to see that this poor sister subhanallah
was pushed to this level
and what else can we say till next time